blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so i am uh for better or for
worse
sort of continuing my maya culpa i have
completely been underestimating
the relevance power importance and
potential
of this q anon wing of the republican
party i talked about this i think it was
on tuesday or wednesday this week i
think tuesday
and every day i am learning more about
the reality
that um we probably should have paid a
little more attention to this to begin
with there's a new vice article pointing
out that
q anon already has 19 candidates running
for congress in 2022.
david gilbert writes that as the gop
becomes more receptive to the conspiracy
theory
more of the cult's followers are running
for office
with 18 months to go before the 2022
midterms q and on supporters are already
seizing on the gop's embrace of the
conspiracy theory
and growing their hats throwing their
hats in the ring for a seat in congress
so far 19 people who have publicly shown
support for the q
anon conspiracy theory have declared
their intention to run
in house and senate races across the
country according to a media matters
investigation
recall our revelation
uh i guess we would call it our
discovery from earlier this week that
based on new polling
one in five americans on average yes
more in some parts of the country than
others but one in five americans on
average
believes at least one of the three major
human on conspiracy theories the one
about the child pedophilia
inspired by satan the one about there
may need to be a violent uh sort of a
takedown of the centers of power in
order to save humanity or
the country or whatever and what's the
third one
um oh the third one is yeah like the the
conspiracy of
you know the elites that are secretly
controlling
and manipulating deep state type stuff
those are the kind of three major
branches of q anon conspiracies
20 of the country believes at least one
of those and we are seeing this
reflected not only in voters
but we are now seeing it reflected in
candidates now the logical fear would be
if 20 of america believes at least one
of these conspiracy theories
and you've got what will probably by
november of 2022 be dozens of candidates
who believe the stuff running
the 20 that believe in that stuff are
going to go and vote for the candidates
and we're going to have more q anon
in the house of representatives rather
than less i think that we would
safely say right now marjorie taylor
green is a q anon person
um in some sense matt gates is a q anon
type
i don't know what the full like is
madison cawthorne q anon is lauren
beaubert queueing on i don't know
but when you see 19 people already
running with a year and a half to go
that's not good that's not good
the article invites goes on to say all
but one of the candidates are running as
republicans
the single anomaly or anomaly both are
acceptable pronunciations is mindy
robinson running as an independent in
nevada's
third congressional district under the
patriot party
of nevada banner like 14 others on the
list robinson was a candidate for
congress in 2020
uh and like all but two of those she
lost oh okay this says the two
candidates who won
that are q are lauren beaubert and
marjorie taylor green
both up for re-election um the number of
q anon supporting candidates is likely
to increase as the 2022 election
approaches
in 2020 the final tally of q anon
supporters
who ran was 97 according to media
matters
for america like many of the candidates
on the list bobert and greene
have sought to distance themselves from
the most extreme fringes of the q anon
movement
despite repeatedly displaying support
for the conspiracy on social media
and in video interviews this is a real
concern
now i don't know that we could have done
that much more
to stop this um before
now in the sense that there was not
really the sense that this would be
significant
and so if you can't convince people that
something's serious
how do you get them to activate against
it i don't know but now we know it's
serious and now we know that it's real
and one of the things i'm most
interested in seeing
in these upcoming trump rallies trump is
restarting the maga rallies and he's
getting the old 757 tuned up and
getting worked on so he can start flying
into rallies one of the things i'm
curious about
aside obviously from seeing what donald
trump's sort of emotional state is
the interviews with the supporters at
these rallies it's not an election
year 2021 it's not even a midterm
election year it's just a random it's a
non-big election year
what is the mindset and the tone and the
mood and the perspective of the people
that go
to a june 2021 trump rally
and that i think will give us a sense of
how prevalent
this q movement is within the people
that are going out to support trump
there's a real question as to is the q
movement more of a stay home and type
stuff up on the computer type group
or is it more of a go out to the rallies
type group
i fear that it's the latter and that
they are going to really make their
presence known and felt
strongly uh during the 2022 campaign and
every indication now that this is far
more serious
far more serious than we imagined i want
to talk
next about one of the the real
implications of this bogus
arizona audit that's taking place of
absentee ballots
looking for bamboo fibers and all sorts
of other stuff
the the impact of the arizona audit is
not going to be
joe biden retroactively loses arizona
the impact of the arizona audit is not
going to be
joe biden is removed from the white
house and trump is reinstated to use the
word that
they've been throwing around for the
last week or so but there
is going to be an impact from this audit
and there's a really good article
in npr about this by miles parks called
experts call it a clown show
but arizona audit is a disinformation
blueprint um explaining it's not an
audit
it's an audit in name only according to
matt masterson
a former department of homeland security
official who helped lead the election
security prep for the last election
he says it's a threat to the overall
confidence of democracy
all in pursuit of continuing a narrative
that we know to be a lie
this is a really important thing to
understand maybe there are people
who think the arizona audit and the
search for bamboo fibers and all of this
stuff
could lead to a change in the arizona
results or a change in the 2020 results
overall it's not going to
but even without achieving that it still
is achieving something that should be
very scary to all of us which is it
continues to put in people's minds the
idea
that our elections are just a
free-for-all they don't work
when a candidate wins by millions and
millions of votes maybe they actually
lost by millions and millions of votes
and it just further reinforces the idea
that hey
the election results are sort of like
opinion much the same way where you
might like one flavor bubble tea and i
like a different flavor
or i might think that one type of cherry
ice cream is good and you might say
no cherry garcia is the best one right
it equates a position on abortion like
what's my opinion about whether abortion
shouldn't be legal to who won is just an
opinion
and we can challenge it and we can use
any mechanism that we can think of to
try to challenge that
that's the crisis that matt masterson is
pointing out here
masterson says the strategy chosen by
the arizona
republican state senate leaders is
working as intended
to undermine confidence in the outcome
of last year's vote and this is the
point even if it doesn't overturn it
it undermines confidence in elections in
general the process is a simple exercise
in how disinformation spreads and takes
hold in 2021 and experts fear it
presents a blueprint for other states
and lawmakers to follow
one that's already showing signs of
being emulated across the country and
this is the key line right here
masterson says now we have a playbook
out there
where if you don't like the results by
the way in an election that wasn't
particularly close
you claim you didn't lose and in fact
the process itself
was rigged against you and the steps are
first create a false reality
that's the first step the second step is
hit the airwaves which they did very
early and continue to do
the third step is use doubt to sow more
doubt and then you go
into next election with people already
primed to doubt whatever it is uh that
they hear from you
that is the three-step process and
unfortunately
i don't know if these people are evil
geniuses who are thinking hey you know
what
this arizona thing is not going to
accomplish anything in terms of
arizona 2020 but this is going to see
doubt and it will create a pretext for
people
to claim any election we lose was
fraudulent
i don't know that they're really evil
geniuses in their thinking in those
terms but it doesn't matter because
that's the effect that it has
and so much like i said in the last
segment when we start seeing these new
trump rallies
supposedly later this month maybe not
until july when we start seeing them
what is going to be the mood of the
people in the crowd
about the legitimacy legitimacy of any
election because i believe that what
we're going to see here very clearly is
you know trump's going to pick his
favorites for 2022
and maybe a whole bunch of them are
going to lose maybe some will win we
don't yet know but
if they lose yes it hurts trump's shot
at 2024 if he can't successfully be the
king maker in 2022
but does anybody have any doubt that
they're going to say guys listen
democrats control the house now
democrats control the senate joe biden
controls the white house
of course they rigged it of course they
rigged it so it seems to me
a foregone conclusion if they don't get
what they want in 2022
they're going to say it was all
fraudulent and the stuff they're doing
now
including in arizona is going to be used
as a pretext to gin up the idea that if
you don't like the results
it's totally legit now in american
politics to say
the results were rigged very scary stuff
let me know what you think you can find
me on twitter
at deepakman what if you could read
10 books in just one sitting that's
exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
all right welcome back to the program it
is a uh it's a great day it's a great
show today we may even keep this one
remember that we are mostly dependent
on people who grab memberships at
joinpakman.com
today's the last day where you can take
advantage of that
wild memorial day discount the coupon
code is memorial21 and you can use it on
any membership quite literally any
membership you like
at joinpakman.com all right let's talk
to some people let's hear from the
people that's really what we're here to
do
you can get in touch with me via the
david pakman show discord which you
really should be part of anyway i think
we've got 13 or 14 000 members now on
the discord it's completely free
i'm selling you nothing other than a
good time you can go to davidpakman.com
discord let's go first today
to ford from baton rouge
louisiana ford you are on the air
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine yeah
hey uh my question is in regards to
historical statues and
building names um i think it's pretty
fair to say that
almost every u.s president history has
been a racist to some extent uh chomsky
was talking a little bit about this the
other day
uh we're talking a lot about renaming
buildings named after particularly uh
right-wing political figures because of
their racism
but this gets kind of confusing to me
because i don't understand what kind of
calculus goes into like which figures
are acceptable to name buildings after
because plenty of figures that we're
usually okay with like something like
lincoln or
racist as well sure so does it have more
to do with like social progress in the
context of the title they live or how do
we decide who it is and is not okay to
name buildings after
i don't think that there's any set rule
i mean this is what makes it so
difficult and you know last week when
radical radical congresswoman marjorie
taylor green said you know i would even
oppose taking down hitler statues so
that we can learn
from them and it's like have you heard
of books marjorie and a bunch of german
people wrote to me and they said
there are no hitler statues to take down
we took them all down or we prevented
them from from being built
because it's so clearly over the line i
think with lincoln
there's a context where lincoln as an
individual
what was a was a racist as you described
that that's not a crazy thing to say
by modern standards at the time his
views
about race were probably uh
sort of in line with the casual racism
of many people but he thought
slavery had to be done away with and
that's really what he's remembered for
he's not known as someone for example
with like a confederate general why are
they notable
they're notable because they fought a
war to keep slavery legal
and maybe they had a black friend to use
some kind of stupid term that now is
used but what they're known for what
their legacy is they fought a war
to keep slavery legal abraham lincoln on
the other hand and by the way
i don't really care about statues anyway
so i'm just kind of going through
this as a thought experiment abraham
lincoln on the other hand
was likely casually racist as you say
but he said we must end slavery and
slavery should not be legal and that's
sort of his legacy
so the context of the statue is
different is that does that make sense i
mean it doesn't answer
how you decide about any particular
figure
um yeah that makes a lot of sense um it
is really confusing like you say
i guess uh so what you're saying is just
kind of contextualize the individual and
the time frame that they lived in and
then like who was driving social
progress like lincoln was i mean
somebody who's against the civil rights
act yeah
and the thing is that there are people
now who
love the confederacy and whatever who
would disagree
with my characterization about a
confederate general they would say no no
the legacy of a confederate general is
not fighting for slavery
it's fighting for the constitutionally
enshrined states rights that this
country was founded upon and then we
have an argument right
so i think that it's tough because
there's sort of very obviously
over-the-line examples like hitler
but then there's a lot of other ones
where
the lincoln versus confederate isn't a
good example but there are grayer areas
for sure
my thing my thing by the way my thing
ford is i just
i have a hard time caring about statues
it's like i'm worried about we got to
get people healthcare let's get people a
living wage let's
let's make let's deal with climate so
for me it's hard to even
think super seriously about statues
that that's a good point um it feels
like statues are a big focus right now
because you know
the culture war on the right is a really
big deal for them of course
well like noam chomsky said during my
interview with him earlier this week
the cultural issues are a replacement
for actually offering policy that helps
people
right that's why the right isn't like
policy focused anymore it's more about
just the culture war
absolutely yeah thank you david i
appreciate that it was a wonderful phone
call
all right ford from baton rouge
beautiful
beautiful phone call why don't we go
next to oh i don't know
um why don't we try george from chicago
george you're on the air
how's my audio your audio is maybe about
a six and a half seven not bad
oh all right well david
sir oh i'm sorry your audio just dropped
to a 5.
oh oh geez i'm sorry i'll try again real
quick okay yeah please
okay uh david i heard a article in the
comments that talked about um
rising uh or some of the stimulus uh
preventing people from going
into uh the workforce do you think it's
a
little bit too soon to say whether or
not that's a good call to do that story
yet
yeah so i did a segment about this
earlier this week and spent about you
know 10 or 15 minutes talking about it
here's my view on this because i think
this is really important
there it's a very popular right-wing
argument right now to say
because of the enhanced unemployment
people are just raking in money by not
working and so this is causing all these
restaurants to be unable to hire people
and
um here's the bottom line enhanced
unemployment benefits
uh and and i think it's september 6th
but it's i believe sometime in september
once that happens
all sorts of people that right now might
be choosing not to go back to work
because if they go back to work they
might make the same
or a little less or whatever because of
the enhanced unemployment
they're going to need to go and get get
jobs they're just going to need to go
and do it unemployment's going to end
and it's very easy to just look at a
social welfare program
and point to what you would consider to
be the free riders or people taking
advantage of it making more off of the
program than from work
but that's going to come to an end
enhanced unemployment was hugely
beneficial to the country at a
macroeconomic level
and in the next three to four months i
believe this is going to resolve itself
george as people are going to need jobs
there's going to be no more unemployment
and some businesses will have to pay
more and there's no question about it
and there is an argument to be made
in some states if you can't get people
to come and work for you
maybe you're not paying a high enough
wage it is true
that dropping enhanced unemployment on
top of state unemployment
distorts the labor market that's
absolutely undeniable
the question is is it exposing
that the wages are too low in some cases
the answer is yes and there's not a
one-size-fits-all answer to that
different states have different minimum
wages but i believe this will be
resolved
by october 15th okay okay thank you i
just thought that article was a little
bit too soon and it lampooned the
stimulus a little bit too much
trying to get you just a real quick
question yeah um i'm going to be through
uh
uh whether you call it fortune or
unfortunate circumstances i'd say
fortunate
um in boston massachusetts uh next week
anything in particular you think i
should see
have you been to the city before uh no
sir
okay when when i would you know when
people when i was in boston and people
would come visit me if they had never
been before
i would sort of give them a tour that
includes
the popular touristy area of you know
the boston common area and newbury
street
along the river between boston and
cambridge you definitely want to go over
to cambridge check out harvard yard
check out mit check out that area
but then also go down to southie and
dorchester
go to castle island uh go to
some of these other you know new hip
neighborhoods
what else uh yeah i don't know i mean
that's probably already enough for a
weekend
yeah yeah thank you all right uh have a
going david all right george
absolutely a perfect phone call really
can't we we're off to a great start
today let's see if we can keep it going
let's go next to eduardo from
brooklyn brook is that brooklyn new york
of course
it is brooklyn new york it's not
brooklyn center minneapolis for example
minnesota rather
well i hope not i
i think i'm in the best part of new york
i believe
beautiful all right what's on your mind
today i just wanted to run something by
you if you don't mind
uh something i've been thinking about
i've been following a lot of the uh
you know the people recounting the votes
and everything
and obviously nobody's found anything
incriminating or whatever
uh but do you think that maybe they're
just looking for
just a tiny little spark that would just
like justify everything they're doing
and if they do find just like one
irregularity it will just be like
a blitzkrieg of of attacks on everything
yeah what their and here's the problem
even if they find
nothing they'll just say the fraud was
hidden well enough so that we haven't
yet uncovered it and we need to keep
going so i would even go further than
you
if they find anything at all
then of course they will say we need to
redo every election in every state
there's no question about that
but even if they find nothing they will
say
we have reason to believe that there is
still something to uncover
we need more time we need more money we
need more ballots to review they don't
care and this is the problem with
conspiratorial thinking
if you find evidence it's evidence of
the conspiracy
if you find no evidence the evidence has
been covered up and it's evidence of the
conspiracy
every either way they think the
conspiracy is real
it's the true definition of a catch-22
exactly
exactly yeah eduardo i have to ask i
you you have the slightest accent where
is that from i love it
well i'm originally from rio in brazil
ah
but i grew up in the uk in london and uh
i moved to new york about 10 years ago
that's interesting you it there's this
the slightest british hint to your
accent it's it's a it's really a perfect
accent i would say
well that's where i learned english
actually yeah um
do you mind if i ask you another
question no please which comes from uh
my girlfriend uh because we watch your
show together and uh
she is uh fascinated by you know
we both fascinated by languages and you
always you always have like a very
erudite take on on sort of world global
views uh-oh
and and i know but she she
wanted to ask you she can't be here
unfortunately right now but uh she
wanted to ask you
if you think that there is a um
the way that the situation that people
see in the u.s obviously the u.s is a
proponent of a lot of like things that
happen around the world but
do you think how other news uh translate
the little nuances of what's happening
in the us
uh in a way that sort of does it justice
or do you think that it's like they
they sort of put it in their own
perspective in it
this is a great question you know i can
only speak to this
in terms of argentina because i i watch
a lot of argentinian news because i was
born in argentina
and i see how they cover things in the
united states
it i don't brazil yeah i would imagine
so
i can't say that the
um i can't say that the coverage i see
of the us and argentina
is dishonest or inaccurate but it
definitely lacks
context so if your only exposure to
what's happening in the u.s
is argentinian news reporting about the
u.s
i think you definitely don't really
understand what's going on because it
lacks context
and it may be unreasonable to expect i
mean listen when we get american news
about france
it lacks conflicts there's no there's no
doubt about it it's not unique
but no i think that a lot of people if
they mostly get their american news
from local foreign media they probably
don't fully understand the context in
which things are happening here
but do you think that's a in the grand
scheme do you think that that
basically is detrimental to the world of
america do you think they sort of
uh it makes it a little lighter for them
to digest
i think if on balance it prop the
coverage of the us
globally probably makes people's opinion
of the u.s
worse not better that would be my guess
yeah i'm with you yeah uh thanks david
all right my friend but all right take
care appreciate the call thank you
really really great phone call
uh why don't we keep it going it's hard
to imagine we could keep such a streak
going today
but i'm really gonna try let's go to
and i know that last time i
mispronounced your name is it
tamesha from new york city
yes tamisha how are you hi how are you
um david do you know why i like you so
much
no i i'm shocked you do to be honest
no i like you because i think of things
and i see things happening and then
i go to watch a video of yours and you
think
exactly are similar to the way i think
okay
but um i wanted to ask you a question
about um
i know that there's been a policy in the
talks about
free college i know biden was talking
about community colleges being free
yeah and um i know some people talk
about state colleges
and when i talk to my friends about it i
say oh my son who's 11
by time he goes to college it'll be free
and when we talk about like college
funds
but then they tell me that um college is
only free for like the really really
poor is that true that it won't be
like everybody has access to that well
the thing the thing that's difficult
to mesha is that we don't know yet
because
there are proposals uh there are
proposals for
full free state college regardless of
income
there are proposals for means-tested
programs where
if family income is above a certain
amount
then it's not free but below that amount
it is free but what i will tell you is
this
every proposal i've seen from any
any serious democrat would be
at least free community college below
very re it won't only be for people
under the federal poverty line
it won't be that it'll be free for a
significant portion of the population
the real question is will this pass i
have no idea we just don't know yet for
now
there's you know nothing has passed so
if it were me right now
and i don't have a kid right now to save
for college
i would be operating financially under
the assumption that college would not be
free for them
and hey you know what if it ends up
being free that's great
well yeah i guess i'm being optimistic
yeah of course
i do agree with you that you should plan
for any outcome
yes but um and i think i find like the
fact that it wouldn't be
like the income part of it bothers me
only a little bit because
you know most people even if you have a
decent salary you still fall and
you're still not necessarily rich of
course you know
um even if you have a decent salary and
those people still tend to be forgotten
no doubt and this was an issue sometimes
you know with with obamacare
in many states the way that the
subsidies are set
there's no i don't remember what state
it was but there are states where the
subsidies if you're a self-employed
person and you have to go and buy
a plan on the mark healthcare market you
get a
really big subsidy if you earn under 10
000 a year
and a smaller subsidy between 10 and 20
and a smaller subsidy between 20 and 30
but like by the time you get to 48 000
a year the subsidy ends so basically if
you earn 48 000
a year 88 000 a year or
888 000 a year everybody gets no subsidy
once you get to 48.
that seems terrible it's that middle
that really gets squeezed in that
situation
and so something to be aware of and and
let's hope that it doesn't happen if
indeed there's a college funding plan
put put together
yes hopefully yeah and one more thing um
i know you talked about this a week or
so ago two weeks maybe
about the mayor in chicago i think it
was where she was
saying that she would only um
she would only be interviewed by
non-white journalists
yeah and like i agree with you where i
feel like
if you discrim if you are calling out
discrimination by using discrimination
and that's
not only hypocritical but it defeats the
purpose yes
but i also from another perspective i
think i
i'm only guessing i can't speak for her
but i'm thinking that
since you know the history of blacks in
this country is where we're seen as
um less than we're seen as um
not human we were in the past or were
seen as
uh as stupid lazy like those are some of
the stereotypes
i think that that um what she was trying
to do or what maybe she's trying to do
is say
we're trying to i'm trying to even the
playing field and give us an upper hand
upper hand yeah and to clarify on that
to misha for people who don't know
chicago mayor laurie lightfoot said that
around i don't remember
if it was just like around memorial day
or what it was she said that
she was only going to be interviewed by
non-white journalists
for this period short period of time and
interview requests by white journalists
would be rejected now what i said at the
time was
if this is just a policy this is this is
just racism i'm against it completely
however if it had been presented as hey
you know what
this is a city the city of chicago which
has a huge non-white population
and yet most of the interviews with
elected officials that show up in the
newspapers are with white journalists so
for this one week i am going to
prioritize being interviewed
by journalists of color great who
beautiful however the way that it was
said was i will be rejecting interview
requests from white journalists and
and you know what i just think it was it
was completely improperly framed and i
agree with you that there's a right way
to do this and there's a wrong way to do
this
yeah and that's basically what is trying
to figure out the right way yeah to
give us an even playing field because
most of the time what what um black
people are asking for is equality not
necessarily a handout
right we take it it's just to even the
playing
field i'm with you i'm with you that's
not really always the right way to do it
i agree with you
all right tamesha always great to hear
from you
thank you all right there is tamesha uh
let's take a quick break if you're
holding
don't hang up we're going to try to keep
the streak of perfect phone calls going
right after this short break
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
all right welcome back let's go back to
the phones uh you can they're not really
phones anymore they're really internet
tubes
um davidpakman.com discord is where you
can find it
let's go first to shaelin from dc
is that washington dc hey yeah can you
hear me yes i can
hey yeah so i had a quick question about
the recent comments from general
flynn and donald trump
uh with the recent them basically saying
like oh
that i support a coup and all that yeah
how do you think this is going to play
out
for elections in the next couple years
seeing like january 6 was a thing and
i guess just like election election
integrity being a huge thing on the
ballot
like how do you think this is going to
play out for democrats in the coming
years well i think that
uh there's we it's hard to say in the
coming years because there's so many
variables but at this point republicans
aren't even pretending to care about
election integrity or the rule of law
all they care about is
what laws can we pass or what laws can
we ignore
so that we win and with the news that
donald trump now is telling people he
thinks he'll be reinstated as president
by august michael flynn saying we should
we should do a coup like in myanmar or
minamar as the person in the audience
called it when they asked the question
um what what really is going to shape
the future
of i mean like right now i'm mostly
thinking about 2022 and 2022 will
influence 2024.
it's what do they actually pass in terms
of voter suppression and election
suppression
law and they're trying to do a lot of
stuff in a whole bunch of different
states
does trump starting up his rallies again
which we learned he's going to do
in order to probably support the people
he likes for 2022
does it inspire more republicans to get
out and vote or does it inspire more
democrats to go out and prevent
another resurgence of trumpian insanity
but
the in the background of all this my
fear
um is that this is going to inspire more
violence and at this point it's not
hypothetical i mean
we know that they can be inspired to
violence because we look at january 6th
so when i see them talking about a coup
and trump talking about being reinstated
i worry about more of the same and i
think it's it's a real scary time right
now
awesome thanks for the answer all right
thanks jalen very good sounds like
you're getting a message there so i'm
going to let you go
let's go next to
uh oh i don't know we've been we've been
so in the u.s today let's try
peter from dublin peter you're on the
air
hi david how are you doing i'm doing
well long time listener first time
caller
uh pleasure american x is a bit of a
guilty pleasure for me i suppose uh wow
maybe
i used to be a fan of that classic
fantasy series the west wing many years
ago
yes uh i just wanted to say that i i
really really enjoyed
listening to your balanced well-informed
commentary about
politics so uh thanks for that
my general comments i do have one more
specific
thing so um it is related to the
commentary
uh piece so it's about margarita green
favorite character i'm sure uh so i'm
just wondering
don't you think that mainstream media
are making the same mistake
in relation to her that they did with
trump and and what i mean is
they give her a lot of free screen time
every time he says something completely
absurd or
you know outrageous and we know she does
it a lot so
will does not promote a dangerous
character even further like
it seems to be already happening if you
look at her fundraising figures and
you know the mainstream media are known
the wiser after how they promoted trump
in 2016 and like she knows very well how
trolling works
so wouldn't be just safer to just you
know to not feed the troll and
and uh ignore her stupid comments
instead of going yeah
it's another stupid thing i know she's a
member of congress
but what do you think about that here's
the problem this comes up all the time
this is an ongoing question um here's
the problem
if serious media
and left-wing media ignores her
uh and right-wing media continues to
hold her up
as a hero that is the only
message that gets out now you might say
well
right-wing media only talks about her
because she's so triggering
to to normal media and left-wing media i
don't think that that's the case
i think that this is someone who because
of her personality and because of her
affiliation with trump
is popular in right-wing media now is
there some degree to which you're right
that as she gets more media coverage
right-wing media becomes even more
sycophantic about her and gives her more
coverage
yeah probably but they would be covering
her anyway and the problem with
not addressing that there is someone in
the house of representatives
who thinks masks are like the holocaust
and i think she was one of the people
with lauren bobert who wants guns on the
house floor and all this different stuff
the problem is that if reporters ignore
it and left-wing media ignores it
uh the ideas don't go away it is seen
increasingly by the right as
legitimate to have someone like this in
the house of representatives and i fear
that it just grows so i've just not seen
any evidence that
ignoring it quote ignoring it is really
a solution to anything
okay and do you think that she she's
doing that in purpose like
is it a marketing tactics because it
does remind me very much of
the marketing tactics of the airline
ryanair that's
in the news recently because of what
happened in belarus so yeah
their ceo many years ago like every now
and then he would say something
completely ridiculous
uh publicly like that he will only
introduce you know one pilot to save
money or or offer standing tickets or
something something completely
impossible
yeah and all the newspapers at the time
of radio shows would pick it up and
start discussing as if it was a serious
thing and every time they would say oh
low cost airline locust airlines so that
you know got embedded
in people's brains so is it possible
that she's doing that on purpose so that
you know if
as you said you know if somebody more
right wing leaning
will watch you know mainstream media
they will see her and it will be just oh
look at her
owning those lip guards again you know
like is is this do you think it
is she's smart like this or is it just
you know accidental that
i think that it's a combination i think
to some degree she knows that there are
types of things that she can say that
will get her attention
a lot of it isn't good attention i don't
think she's so brilliant at it though
that she's doing it in a way that really
benefits her i think there's a good
chance she gets absolutely crushed
in in november of 2022 and then that's
it for her
so i think that it it it works in
getting her attention right now
whether it will really achieve or serve
some bigger purpose
i don't know i think it actually could
be disastrous for her
david thank you very much uh much
appreciate your time all right
from ireland very much appreciated thank
you so much
uh let's see why don't we speak next to
oh i don't know there's really just it's
it's really a uh
it's it's hard to pick because there's
so many great people
holding how about ryan from el paso
texas ryan you're on the air
uh hey david can you hear me all right
yes i can but uh discord is blinging in
the background that's the only issue
give me one second please okay
um so uh i'm i'm but i'm a bit of a
younger folk um
i'm a 13 years old and i was just
wondering
how i could get a little more
politically involved you know
because most people don't really uh like
you're just the kid you don't really
understand and i would just
you know like how i could sort of just
get myself out there
beautiful this is a great question
getting involved at your age is a
amazing thing to do so my
guess is most things you can't run for
right now because you probably need to
be 18 but that doesn't mean you can't
help out on a campaign so what i would
say is
maybe starting right in el paso um is
there
i don't know what the form system of
government there is but is there a
mayoral candidate you can help
is there a city council candidate that
you can help what about what's going on
in school board presumably you're going
to be in school for some
some years what about figuring out who
would you like to work with for school
board
is there school government that you
could maybe get involved in there's
really a lot of options it's just a
matter of knowing where to look
also by the way a lot of non-profits
that you could volunteer for at age 13
you might need a you know a parent
permission or something like that
a lot of non-profits are working on
political issues so like if your
political issue you care about is
education or homelessness or whatever
you can probably find a non-profit to
volunteer with that would work
on that issue so there's really no
shortage of ways to get involved right
now
okay uh that's that was my only question
thank you david all right ryan let let
us know if you get involved in something
okay
okay all right ryan from el paso i have
to tell you
upper management written all over them
from what i'm hearing 13 years old
getting involved i love it
um all right why don't we go to charlie
from
ann arbor michigan i presume
charlie from ann arbor michigan you're
on the air please don't break the streak
of perfect phone calls charlie
we're on a roll here
oh and charlie's gone we couldn't do it
we almost
almost almost had a perfect full session
without any dropped calls or that's
really sad
let's try luke from indiana luke from
indiana please save us
luke i can hear you sort of what's going
on me
yeah oh how's it going it's going well
so basically what i wanted to talk about
is
a lot of people that don't live in rural
areas don't understand
truly how deep the uh urban rural divide
is
like yeah with the vaccinations we've
been hanging at about 40
in indiana for weeks now right
and it's just not going up yeah you know
i um
i actually went to indiana a couple of
years ago
and i was in rural northern indiana so
it was like uh
goshen and um oh really i'm about uh
i'm about an hour west that i'm in
valparaiso okay yeah it was like goshen
and shipshawana and all these little
little places
and spending some time there i under
it's like
of course all those people voted for
trump you drive around
all you see is uh amish folks
shooting ranges and evangelical churches
if that's what you grow up around and
you you're not
exposed to different types of people
you're not exposed to
hey there's a whole alternative view
here of empiricism and science
of course abortion and guns are the most
important issues and of course you voted
for donald trump even if half the stuff
he says
isn't even um is isn't isn't is not even
uh
true and sincere so yeah i think that a
lot of people who just spend their time
in cities
they don't get how it gets to this point
in the rural parts of the country and i
think it would be useful for people to
spend some time there and better
understand how it happens as you're
pointing out
oh yeah and i think a lot of the problem
too is a lot of the people here like you
said they grew up in that scenario
yeah and they don't feel like anyone's
trying to reach out and change their
mind at all like
right i live in one of the more outside
of indianapolis it's one of the more
liberal places in indiana because we
have a steel mill about
40 minutes away that's one of the
biggest
employers in the area right but even
that a lot of those people voted for
trump just because they don't think that
any of the democrats are doing anything
to reach out to them they feel pretty
alienated
right and a lot of them care about
economics more than anything
but yeah no one's reaching out to you
you can't expect them to change i don't
think yep i think as a great starting
point
it would be great for people that are
more urban on the left to spend some
time in these areas to just start
understanding what's going on i
appreciate you bringing that point up of
course
all right luke from indiana thank you
very much an almost
unblemished set of phone calls today
with just one dropped call and otherwise
almost perfect audio
people getting to questions beautiful
beautiful thing
i'm sorry i wasn't able to speak to
everybody who's holding i see about 30
other people holding
we will take calls again and i hope to
speak to you the next time
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow great perks and benefits
as well read about them
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week first one is
hey david everybody's obsessed with
critical race theory but do its critics
even understand what it is
some of them do and many of them don't i
saw one conversation
uh with mark lamont hill and
i don't remember who the other guy was
where the other guy had no idea
whatsoever
we covered it the other guy had no idea
whatsoever what critical race theory was
and every time
mark lamont hill said okay fine you're
against it but what is it
the guy deflected he clearly had no idea
i saw a different conversation that mark
lamont hill
had with a guy from some sort of i think
it was like a center-right thing tank
not one that i was super familiar with
and the guy could at least list some
people who he believed
were influenced by critical race theory
even though mark lamont hill said those
aren't real really critical race
theorists and he had some more
connection now you could argue
i disagreed with the guy or i agreed or
whatever but
there are a lot if you're asking me
about your aunts posting stuff to
facebook about critical race theory
most people don't know what it is and
it's not an insult or
an attack critical race theory much like
many of these theories
mostly exists in the academic world so
it's it's sort of expected and natural
that tons of people wouldn't know very
much about it
it's just become popularized through
controversy
such that you have a whole bunch of
people who know nothing about it who are
talking about
it anyway now i've i've given my
perspective before
on on what it is and what i think about
it that that is valuable and and less
valuable
and a whole bunch of people got mad and
wrote to me and many said
that's not really what it is or you're
sort of partially right
or whatever the case may be um i think
that
at a certain point there is a sort of no
true scotsman fallacy you get to with a
lot of these things and this was
this is really common with jordan
peterson and his followers actually
where any time i would try to do a
critique of something jordan peterson
said
a significant portion of his followers
wouldn't actually engage with what i say
but rather would claim that's not really
the position of jordan peterson you're
bastardizing what jordan peterson said
and to some degree this is happening on
both sides with critical race theory
there
are people who when confronted with a
reasonable critique of critical race
theory as it applies to some aspects of
society
will say you're not being honest or you
don't understand what it actually is
and then you either have a conversation
about what it actually is
which sometimes goes somewhere and very
often doesn't i've seen some
some online live debates about it where
they can't even define what it is and
it's just a worthless
waste of three hours and that's sad but
you also do have people
on the right who reflexively oppose it
in total
even as a framework for analyzing any
aspect of society while having
absolutely no idea what it is i think
the best thing
to do first and foremost is just
understand the structure
and let the other person tell you what
it is you think
they believe it says about society so
critical race theory much like most
critical theories
has its basis in foucault
post-modernism post-structuralism you
could argue
argue jean-paul sartre the
the the framework should at least
generally be understood
the importance of language and the way
we talk about things within such
theories you should generally have an
understanding of
it's its connection to economics and
there's
and again this is where some some people
will go nuts so i even hesitate to say
this but
you can you can make the case that the
type of analysis
has some roots in marxist
thought now it doesn't mean that
to believe in critical race theory you
have to be a marxist in a literal sense
it's just
we're talking about some of the overlaps
um and most people don't know that
most even just these basics most people
do not know
the right is caricaturing critical race
theory as
it's the story that all whites are
racist
or even white supremacists and that's
the lens through which
everything must be seen period full stop
that's an unfair caricature of critical
race theory there's plenty to criticize
about critical race theory
based on a real understanding of it
there's really no need to go to nonsense
stuff like much of the write is doing
but to answer the question do critics of
critical race theory even understand it
um if you're talking about what you're
seeing posted to twitter and facebook
and much of social media and even what's
happening on fox news
the answer is no the vast majority
do not understand it next question today
david vaccination is going really well
in the united states vaccines for
everyone who wants them
how much credit does trump get for
vaccination
listen he gets very little he gets very
little and what i mean is the following
um moderna and pfizer are companies that
existed in the united states long before
trump and they were on the forefront of
medical science johnson and johnson same
thing
uh astrazeneca you know different
vaccine same thing so certainly
trump gets no credit whatsoever for the
fact that some of the usual players
were the first to get moving on vaccines
that would be used
trump gets zero credit for that okay
second question
who thought up the vaccines well you
know the truth is that back in january
the virus was sequenced when it comes to
the pfizer vaccine
turkish immigrants to germany are the
ones who actually put together the the
building blocks of this vaccine it was
ultimately developed and produced by
pfizer trump certainly gets no credit
for that now what did trump do well
operation warp speed operation warp
speed
what trump did is what any
any president short of a true
sort of genocidal psychopath who wants
to prevent vaccine development
would have done which is what trump made
funds available for companies that
wanted to participate in operation warp
speed the big manufacturers did not
participate in operation warp speed from
a development standpoint
and then yes the government agreed to
pre-purchase
a whole bunch of vaccines so that
production could start even before
we knew which candidate vaccine is going
to eventually be the one that's used
you can give trump credit for that if
you want any
sane president would do that okay so
when we give him credit for that what
we're saying is trump didn't go out of
his way
to make it more difficult to get these
vaccines produced and the reason you
have to do this and the reason this is
so commonly done
when you are developing a medication for
an urgent
health situation is if you wait until
approval to start manufacturing you're
behind
so on spec as we call it you start
manufacturing vaccines
before they are actually approved so
that if they're approved you have a
whole bunch
of them ready to go trump allowed that
to happen
he didn't get in the way of that he can
get credit for that he acted like a
normal person on that
on distribution he gets essentially no
credit distribution was a disaster when
joe biden came in
we were vaccinating 800 000 people a day
there were vaccines that were
unaccounted for
there was no plan turned over to joe
biden it was an absolute
complete and total mess so how much
credit does trump get
he gets very little he by down playing
the virus
reduced interest in people getting the
vaccine uh
the distribution was essentially
non-existent trump got vaccinated in
january didn't even go public with that
until march at which point two more
months
of building anti-vaccine sentiment had
been allowed to fester and ferment
so trump gets extraordinarily little
credit
if you disagree with me let me know
hey david is the republican 2022
strategy going to be merely
trump so a lot of people are writing to
me
with versions of this question which is
what are republicans going to run on in
2022
in the midterms uh where everybody in
the house is up for
for election and a third of the senate
is up for election what what are they
going to run on because
there's no policy that they're
advocating for now it's just oppose
the democrats obstruct the democrats as
noam chomsky told us earlier this week
blow up anything you can that democrats
are going to try to do
it's not really policy and that's
absolutely right
i believe that there is no interest from
the republican party in actually going
back to policy for 2022
and as a result the republican party is
taking a risk
that they can make the case that things
are really bad under joe biden and
things have been bad
so what is it going to be that
determines what happens in 2022
it's going to be how is the economy
doing have we recovered from the virus
and remember that
we are just six seven months now from
2022
these races are going to start ramping
up in january february etc
what does the economy look like at the
time if the economy is not so good
and republicans can blame biden then
they have a shot at doing well in the
house and maybe in the senate as well
if there's a resurgence of the virus and
joe biden can't get it under control
that's going to play against democrats
in 2022
but when they remove themselves from any
serious policy discussion
and become the party of no no no that
package is too big
this package is too big we can't afford
it
biden's bad don't let biden do
infrastructure don't don't get
vaccinated
don't do all this different stuff you
are taking a very big political risk
that you will be able to uh say i told
you so as you get to 2022 and say you
need to put us in
order to fix this now donald trump is
going to come in from the top
in all likelihood and start saying these
are the good republicans that you should
support these are the bad republicans
you don't want to support these people
and what influence he has will also
determine what things look like if trump
has lost influence and the economy's
doing well and trump says re-elect
marjorie taylor green and lauren bobert
and they lose that bodes very poorly for
donald trump and the trumpian wing for
2024.
the economy's not so good there's a
resurgence of the virus if inflation
were to get out of control which i don't
think will happen or whatever
and donald trump can come in and say see
you need me back and for now
here's the 50 people i'm supporting and
a bunch of them win
it reinforces trumpian republicanism and
it probably pushes trump to look at
running in a serious way in 2024. so
in 2022 you will also be up against
i mean listen even if trump remains
popular in
november of 2022 and gets behind a bunch
of candidates
they're not going to be as interesting
to many of these trump voters as trump
was himself so there are lots of these
what we might call low-propensity trump
voters who were not engaged in politics
before 2016
who did get out and vote for trump and
while they were there they checked off
whatever trumpian republican was running
on their ballot as well
a lot of them are going to stay home in
2022 unless an
urgent case for look at how terrible
everything is we've got to get
aoc aocl we've got to get pelosi out you
know get them all out sort of thing
a lot of them are going to stay home and
turnout isn't going to be great
then the question is do these
college-educated
and suburban these groups that have been
shifting more and more towards democrats
do they also stay home
as there's generally lower turnout in
midterms or do these
key growing groups for democrats get out
and vote
if the democratic emerging electorate
votes
and the trump people don't because
they're bored with politics
it's probably fine for democrats in 2022
if the economy is bad
and trump weaponizes it with
disinformation
and weaponized propaganda and his voters
get out
it could be very bad for democrats how
does biden do is question one
we don't know the answer yet but seven
eight months from now we're going to be
in the heat of it so plenty of time to
discuss
don't miss today's bonus show it's a
good one
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
we will see you then or otherwise on
monday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman